hey this is press tow
Walker this video has three problems to
find the Shaded
area problem
one ABCD is a square and a FD is a
rhombus suppose EF and CD intersect at
Point
G ABCD is a square with area 625 met a
FD is a rhombus with area 500 M what is
the area of the Shaded region ABC Gea
a problem
two there's a large square and on its
bottom right corner are two squares that
are attached externally and
diagonally the large square has a side
length equal to 60 and each of the small
squares has a side length equal to
20 construct a triangle from the top
left corner of the large Square the
bottom right corner of the square that's
on the right right side and the bottom
left corner of the small square on the
bottom side call this triangle
ABC what is the area of triangle
ABC I thank tazim for the
suggestion problem
three start with a piece of paper with
dimensions of8 and
six fold the paper in the center and
then create two folds like this
fold the left side of the paper so that
the corner goes to the middle of the
paper and fold the right side of the
paper so the upper right corner goes to
the
middle you'll end up with the following
folded piece of paper now make two more
folds so that each new Corner ends up
going to the
middle you end up with this paper
airplane type shape what is the area of
this shape
this problem comes from an Iranian
mathematical
Olympiad now just to show you what this
looks like in another way here's an
animation of how the paper folding would
go we start out with these folds and
then we fold the paper so that the
corners go to the
center we then make two more folds so
that the new corners go to the
center
this is the final resulting shape and we
need to figure out its
area pause the video if you'd like to
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve these
[Music]
problems let's solve problem
one suppose a square ABCD has a side
length that's equal to S so a d is equal
to AB is equal to BC is equal to CD is
equal to S then s^2 is equal to 625
meaning s is equal to
25 in the rhombus construct the height
eh upon the side a d the area of the
rhombus is equal to e * a d which equals
500 but a d is a sideline of the square
so it's equal to
25 so e * 25 is equal to 500 and E is
equal to
20 since a f is a rhombus all of its
side lengths have the same length so AE
is equal to a d is equal to S which
equals
25 now construct the perpendicular EI
upon the side
AB AI is equal to h e which is equal to
20 then bi is equal to AB minus a i
which means bi is equal to 25 - 20 which
equals
5 now let's focus on the right triangle
a i
e i e^ 2 + 202 is equal to 252 which
means I E is equal to the < TK of 252 -
202 so IE is equal to 15
this is a scaled up 345 right
triangle now we're pretty much ready to
solve the
problem the area of the Shaded region is
equal to the area of the rectangle ibcg
plus the area of the right triangle a i
e we know that bi is equal to 5 and we
know that BC is a side length of the
square so it's also equal to 25 so the
area of the rectangle is equal to 25 * 5
the area of the triangle is 20 * 15 all
over 2 this equals 125 + 150 which equal
275 s
m now let's solve problem
two there are many ways to solve this
problem but I will show you a solution
that uses outside the box thinking it's
so simple that even a third grader in
China would probably be able to use this
method to solve
it start by complet leading the square
we will construct the following three
rectangles to construct a larger
Square let's label these lengths the
large square has a side length of 60
each small square has a side length of
20 so this will be 20 then 60 - 20 is
equal to 40 we have 20 over here we have
another 20 then we have 60 minus 20
which will be 40 and finally we have 20
again so how does this dive diagram help
us well notice the area of the triangle
is equal to the area of the large square
with a side length equal to 80 minus the
areas of three different right triangles
so this is one right triangle with side
lengths of 80 and
60 this is a right triangle with side
lengths of 20 and 40 we have a third
right triangle with side lengths of 40
and 80
so that's all we need to figure out this
problem we just need to calculate these
areas so we make this
equation the area of the square will be
equal to 80 s then the first triangle
will be 80 * 60 all over two the second
triangle will be 20 * 40 all over 2 and
the third triangle will be 40 * 80 all
over two we simply do this calculation
and we get the answer of two
th000 now let's solve problem
three so we start out with this piece of
paper we make a fold down the middle we
then make these two folds and we're
going to fold so that the corners go to
the middle so basically we're taking
this original sheet of paper and we're
going to subtract out the areas of these
two right
triangles since we're making a fold down
the middle we know that each of these
horizontal lengths will be equal to half
of six or equal to 3 now what about the
other side length well consider this
constructed
line we are going to fold the left side
to the base of this new triangle but the
base of the new triangle is equal to
three so we know that the original
height is also equal to
three now we end up with this shape so
we have two Isles right triangles with
side lengths equal to three so it's
hypotenuse will be equal to 3 <
tk2 that will be the side length of the
new triangle that we're folding so we
make this fold and this fold and we want
to subtract the areas of the following
two triangles so we need to figure out
the areas of these two
triangles but now these two triangles
will exactly be congruent to the two
folded triangles it'll be slightly
easier to figure out the height from
this
diagram construct this horizontal length
which we know is equal to six so half of
it will be equal to three and that's the
height of each of these triangles and we
know the base is equal to 3 < tk2 so we
have two triangles with a height that's
equal to three and a base that's equal
to 3 < tk2 so we're now ready to do the
calculation the area of the original
piece of paper is going to be 8X 6 then
we subtract out two triangles which have
legs that are equal to three then we
subtract out the areas of two triangles
which have a height of three and a base
of 3 <
tk2 so we simply do this calculation and
we get the result of 39 minus 9 < tk2
which is approximately equal to
26.27 2 and that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world problems one video at a
time